[Applaudissements]
la boîte de nuit la voûte à montréal
ouvre dans quelques heures après plus de
trois mois sans avoir reçu un seul
client
il ya quand même eu vent vml dollars
environ qui a été dans les préparatifs
pour l'ouverture des tabourets et des
tables seront installées sur la piste de
danse pour assurer le respect des
consignes sanitaires de port du masque
sera obligatoire pour les clients et la
température sera prise à l'entrée une
initiative que d'autres joueurs majeurs
de l'industrie ont décidé de suivre une
mousseline on a augmenté la sécurité non
ça c'est vraiment une mesure qui était
nécessaire
on veut justement pas avoir des
dérapages nous permettent de réouvrir
c'est un petit peu un comédien un cadeau
empoisonné qu'on est obligé de rouvrir
ouvrir à 30 % de capacité
françois boitard s'apprête à accueillir
une centaine de clients seulement la
capacité de son bar et de 800 personnes
prendre un verre socialiser et tenter de
ne pas sortir de l'espace délimité un
défi c'est sûr que l'on peut pas leur
permettre de sortir on va dire du
périmètre qu'on a créé pour eux pour
aller danser mais il faut quand même
garder une certaine rigueur
il faut qu'on soit assez malheureusement
sévère parce que si nous ne sommes pas
et à la police qui va passer arias
ils vont nous puis ils vont nous punir
ce fut le cas dans un bar de saint
jérôme il ya quelques jours les clients
ne respectaient pas les consignes de
distanciation la situation aux états
unis inquiète aussi les propriétaires de
bars de montréal les jeunes de moins de
30 ans ne semble pas comprendre la
gravité de la pandémie vont peut-être
miné toute l'industrie de la
restauration des bars 6e j écoute pas
soyez responsable soyez proactif c'est
vraiment vraiment difficile à gérer
vous employez doivent ce premier grand
la fois la police oui tout le monde tout
le monde
oui c'est certain parce que sinon ça
marche pas puis si on n'a pas des
règlements dans en place sous les restos
tous les bars va être fermé
une expérience totalement différente
pour les oiseaux de nuit les
discothèques se sont réinventés
maintenant les clients doivent trouver
le moyen de s'amuser sans trop dansé et
à distance ici marie michel lauzon
radio-canada à montréal